- I'm really excited
to welcome Professor Van Tran here today.
Dr. Tran's work on authoritarian politics
in Myanmar really resonates
with so many of the exciting conversations
that are going on at Yale and
elsewhere at the intersection
of Southeast Asian studies and politics.
Thanks largely to my colleague, Jim Scott,
we have a long standing interest
in Myanmar here at Yale,
and I'm really delighted to be able
to host someone like Dr. Tran,
who has recently completed
a PhD supervised by our
own former PhD student
from Yale, Tom Popinski, who is at Cornell
and she completed her PhD in 2020.
Dr. Tran's dissertation is
a study of public activism
under repression, and she
uses historical case studies
from Myanmar's pro-democracy
movement during military rule
to understand how
pro-democracy movements operate
under military rule.
Given the recent coup in
Myanmar and the return
to military rule, I think
I'm not alone in wanting
to learn more about what
her research has revealed
and to try and help us understand.
In addition, Dr. Tran (indistinct)
policy research institute
(indistinct) organizations in
Myanmar to deliver insights
and policy recommendations
on topics concerning local
governance, digital literacy
and online disinformation.
Her recent analysis and
commentaries on Burmese politics,
appeared on the Washington
Post, Brookings Institution,
Al Jazeera, Associated Press and so on.
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Tran
to our virtual series.
Her talk is entitled
engineering public hostility
against popular movements
Tatmadaw's suppressive repertoire
in urban Myanmar.
I'll turn it over to
you, Dr. Tran. Thanks.
- Thank you so much for this
generous introduction Erik.
Just to clarify, I'm not a professor,
I got my doctorate degree,
but not yet a professor.
But yeah so first of all I'll
just like to say thanks like
to also express my gratitude toward Erik
as well as toward the Council
of Southeast Asian Studies
at Yale for inviting me for this occasion
for this opportunity for me to share
about my research today.
Yeah, and I think even
though I don't get to be
at Yale physically, but at the same time,
it's still very nice that
here that I still can see
a few like familiar faces
as well as I still get
the attendance of a lot
of the prominent scholars
and of course in Burma
studies here as well.
So, with that said I'm very
excited to present my work
and also to have hopefully
likely discussion afterwards.
So yeah so without further
ado I'll just jump right in.
So regarding the talk today.
So Erik has also briefly introduce,
like gave a brief summary
of my dissertation.
So this presentation it comes
from the dissertation itself.
And for the talk today my
presentation it will focuses
on a particular part of the dissertation,
which is the suppressive repertoire,
the strategies by the Burmese
military, the Tatmadaw
in terms of engineering and
provoking public hostility
against the popular urban
pro-democracy movement
during military rule
between 1988 and 2010.
This talk it will proceed as follows.
So, first of all, I will
discuss a little bit
in terms of the existing scholarship,
as well as the existing
reports and research
on the Burmese military
junta suppression of defense.
And via this brief, the
review, I would hope to show
that most of this existing
studies on this particular topic,
they have focused on analyzing
the more straightforward tools
of repression by the junta.
However, there is a gap in
terms of the understanding
about more deceptive strategies
to mobilize public hostility
against the protestors.
So therefore, and from
there I would proceed
to the second part of the presentation
where I aim to shed
light on these strategies
by just across two case studies,
popular pro-democracy protests.
One is the Four-eight Uprising
in 1988 and the second
is the Saffron Revolution in 2007.
And based on my analysis of
original qualitative data,
I hope that via this talk I
be able to show first of all,
a typology of the military
suppressive repertoire,
as well as to show to the
audience today the various effects
of these different strategy combinations.
And before I end the talk,
I will also touch briefly
on how the findings from my research
would also have relevant implications
for the current situation
in post coup Myanmar
as well as for the other
situations of suppression
of the civic space beyond Myanmar as well.
So first of all, what do we know
in terms of the state repression
of dissent in Myanmar.
According to existing independent reports
as well as academic studies and research,
the five decades of military
dictatorship in Myanmar
were a period of brutal repression
against pro-democracy activism.
Like from the 1960s to
the 1970s, to the 19,
sorry, one second, 1980s, up to the 1990s
and throughout the 2000s.
So during like these five
decades what we have witnessed
is how the military rule
has resulted in thousands
of casualties and deaths of the protestors
as well as thousands more arrests.
And these are the very like
quiet well cited numbers
by the reports by Amnesty International
as well as reports by
the special repertoires
on the situation of
human rights in Myanmar.
In addition, after each
of the protest cycle,
the Burmese military junta is also known
to have for the confine the
domestic opposition movement
toward a highly restricted
forum of party politics
that the regime could control.
So in here, right, like
works by Christina Fink
and Kyaw Yin Hlaing as well as
Linnea Beatty together offer
a very informative description
of how the government
was determined to persecute dissidents.
So the regime bestow by making all
of the dissident activities
illegal detaining thousands
of prominent activists and
issuing arrest warrants
for other thousands of activists in exile,
and on top of that only
allowing political parties
with no campaigning
activities to be legal.
And during these five decades,
although less well documented
the regime leaders they have
also run multiple campaigns
to vilify the opposition and mobilize
for public hostility toward protestors.
So also with a goal, right
to quell dissent yet compared
to the more direct tools of repression,
such as protests, crackdowns arrests,
and massacres, et cetera.
The strategy is to
provoke public hostility
much less analyze.
And most of the literature
on this issue so far
in the Myanmar context only draws
from either public propaganda
by the military in 1988
or around 1988, or a handful
of activists accounts
of 1988 protest cycles.
Okay. So for instance, right.
So according to Berto Linares
depiction of the military coup
that ended the Four-eight
Uprising on September 18th, 1988.
In order to disseminate
allegations of the uprising
as harboring criminals,
the state broadcasted,
and also labeled any protests participants
as violent delinquents.
And such type of intentional framing
was also more blatant later
on as state also reported
about the protestors as quote
unquote destructive elements.
And at the junta even announced
that most of the deaths
on the September 18 were
caused by quote looters
and other unsavory elements unquote.
Moreover, according to
other studies, right?
According to a lot of
studies, we also have found
that after the pro-democracy
uprising in 1988,
the military regime held a series
of military press conferences accusing
the main opposition party at the time,
the National League for
Democracy, NLD of being controlled
by the Communist Party of
Burma or foreign forces.
So, most of these types
of studies and reports
that we have seen the materials have come
from the public propaganda
of the military junta.
However, we do have a glance I like
the more deceptive strategies via the work
by Christina Fink where
she quoted the experiences
of student activists
in 1988, who suspected
that military Asians in
plain clothes were trying
to provoke them toward
committing violence or murder
in order to create a chaotic
situation so that the military
would have a justification
for clamping down.
However, overall like one
of these types of studies
or research and reports have
been able to examine fully
the range of the various
strategies, both public,
as well as the covert strategies
to provoke public hostilities
to work the protest movement
and moreover, due to the lack of evidence
from the point of view of the
people on the receiving end
of these strategies, namely the protestors
and the general public
themselves, like via these work
we also have not been
able to really understand
whether these types of
strategies, have they really like
how much have they had in effect.
So therefore this is the
part that I would like
to contribute with my research.
And more specifically,
in order to shed light
on the state leader's accountability
in manufacturing public hostility
toward protest movements,
I analyze original firsthand
evidence from two case studies
of popular pro-democracy protests.
As I said before, the
Four-eight Uprising in 1988
and the Saffron Revolution in 2007.
Not only are they unlikely
cases for the emergence
of civilian hostility toward
the protest movements,
but they also experienced
two different combinations
of safe strategies, which
I would describe later on.
Therefore I find that
studying the public response
toward the peaceful
activists in these two cases
will allow me to highlight
impacts of each type
of those state repertoire.
So, first of all, the protest
events in both 1988 and 2007,
they are unlikely cases
for civilian disruption
and hostility to where the protestors,
since these protests were highly popular
and received widespread approval
from the general public.
And at the same time, the
antagonism and grievances
toward the military regime was also high.
So the Four-eight or
8888 Uprising witnessed
it's first main protests
on August 8th, 1988
and the uprising was a
combination of a cycle
of student activism in Yangon
in the preceding months
due to the student's grievances
toward General Ne Win's
one party dictatorship.
And from mid August onward,
the uprising then became like
a festival during which
the general public,
including factory workers,
farmers, office staff, artists,
homemakers, civil servants
and soldiers throughout
the country turned out
in droves to demonstrate.
However, almost one month later,
the military stitcher coup
and brutally cracked
down on the protesters.
As I said before, on September 18th, 1988.
Later on as for the second revolution
this is a protest cycle that occurred
during September, 2007
and it earned it's name
because it was led by
Burmese Buddhist monks
whose ropes usually have
maroon saffron colors.
The immediate cause was
government sudden reduction
in fuel subsidy that led to a
large increase in fuel prices.
And this brought hardship on
the majority of the population
who lived near or in poverty.
As a result of the amounts
they also started to take
to the streets all over the country.
Over 10 days after the start
of the main protest
starting on September 26th,
the security forces violently cracked down
on the demonstrators and
raided multiple monasteries
that night.
And so consequently, all of
the suffering protests thoughts
around the end of September.
But despite the popularity, both 1988
and 2007 protest events
faced many incidents
where local residents either
stay away from protest events
or actively confronted and
blocked protest marches.
And moreover the military itself
also employ different
combinations of strategies
to provoke anti protestor hostility
and legitimize their repression.
So at first, as you can
see in this table here
in both 1988 and 2007 as each protest
was gaining popularity, the government
did not crack down right
away, but started broadcasting
his allegations of
protestors as criminals.
The regime avoided using the
word protesters to describe
the movement participants,
but instead labeling them
as rioters in order to
promote criminal images.
And at the same time, the state agents,
they also were part of a covert strategy
where they disguised as
civilian observers penetrated
the protest and committed
violence towards security forces
as well as towards civilian targets,
such as attacking the police
and or destroying public properties.
In addition, in 1988, in
order to manufacture images
of quote unquote anarchy which is the word
that the regime later on use
to describe the 1988 events.
So in order to manufacture
these type of anarchy images
that would further sow
distinction between protestors
and the general public and also
to justify a military coup,
the regime can also covertly
incited peaceful protestors,
and dissidents to commit violence
against innocent civilians.
So in order to further examine,
like the different methods
of these types of strategies
as well as to examine
like their varied effects,
I would now turn to
describing to you the data
that I have collected as
well as how I'm planning
to analyze them as well.
So during my field work,
I conducted in-person
semi-structured interviews
and collected written accounts
mostly by Yangon residents
from diverse demographic
and political backgrounds.
And since I try to mirror the
geographical representation
of Yangon residents in my
sample, I can also take advantage
of the largely accidental
exposure and non exposure
to safe strategies among the interviewees
in order to highlight
the strategy's effects
on civilian responses.
And in order to build
trust with the interviewees
while maximizing the
diversity of the sample
I also worked with
private schools, libraries
and institutions in Yangon and
as well as state affiliates
to recruit respondents.
The interview process
stopped once my sample reach,
like all of the sampling criteria,
as you can see in here
regarding the demographic
as well as political representation
and when the data also reached saturation,
which means, when the new interview data
I was mostly redundant and also offer
too little new information.
For the retinal towns, I collaborated
with the same institutions to identify
and collect published
autobiographies, memoirs
and interviews by former
activists during these two decades
between 1988 and 2010 as well.
So with these graphs here, you
can also basically take plans
at the distribution of the
different types of demographics,
like among the respondents
and among the people
whose written accounts
that I have collected here.
Right, so based on my analysis
of these types of data,
what have I found?
So, first of all, regarding
the state strategies
to frame protestors for
violence during both the 1988
and 2007 events, many
interviewees recalled
how the government spread
news through mass media
that rioters hit them on mount
and lay men demonstrators
in order to rob properties,
poison food and water,
burned down cars and destroy
traffic lights, offices
and households.
By broadcasting about
multiple communal unrest
across different townships in
Yangon the authorities wanted
to make the public perceive
an immediate threat
from quote unquote saboteurs
mixing among protestors,
and these types of news
reached many neighborhoods.
And as a result, most of my
interviewees heard these rumors,
even though they might not
have actually witnessed
the alleged sabotage, right?
So this is one example here.
And at the same time in 1988,
the regime also shut down
government offices for weeks
and also blamed the
protestors for the shutdown,
charging them with
vandalizing these offices.
So in the next quote
here, what you'll find
is that this is a former
civil servant who recalled
how she received quote unquote news
about her offices destruction in advance.
Yeah.
And secondly, in order to further produce
the optical illusions of
protestors as criminals,
the state they use their own Asians
to infiltrate peaceful
protests and instigate riots.
In 1988, the state Asians committed arsons
and carry out robberies
in different townships
so as to make local residents
believe in the allegations.
And in 2007, these Asians also
attack the security forces
with bricks and rocks so that
the military could use this
as a justification for soldiers
to shoot protesters later on.
And as you can see from these quotes here,
multiple protests,
participants and observers
have detailed these types
of accounts as well.
Right. But not stopping there, right?
So at the height of the
Four-eight Uprising,
the state itself was also
involved in inciting protester
toward committing
violence toward civilians.
So what happens?
At the height of the
Four-eight Uprising the states
they released prisoners and
also had these prisoners poison
the public water sources
that the protestors drank
and on top of that,
they also hired a people
to attack these activist as well.
And multiple residents in
Yangon witnessed these attempts.
However, as the Rangoon general
strike committee at the time
was worried about the
government scheme to frame
the people's uprising as
chaotic and as anarchic,
they released a public
statement requesting people
not to harm and not to
kill the alleged criminals.
Former student activists in Yangon in 1988
likewise here also recall
how they were involved
in detaining the alleged criminals,
but did not condone killing them.
And in another example provided
by the written accounts
by a strike committee member himself,
after the strike committee caught a monk
with three Legion police
which were homemade weapons.
The committee just interrogated this monk,
confiscated the gingerly,
and then let the monk go.
So overall, right?
The general strike committee at that time,
they also try very hard to make
sure that they could control
these different protesters
and strike groups
and strike committees so as to make sure
that do not commit violence
against innocent civilians.
Therefore, according to
many activists and observers
in 1988, in order to incite
protesters toward suspecting
and also killing innocent civilians,
the military resorted to
using agents provocateurs.
So first, in cases
where the strike committee's
petro alleged criminals,
the state agents, they infiltrated
the public interrogations
and also provoked public
anger, which drove people
to behave those that they had arrested
without concrete evidence of crimes.
And one Yangon residents
described such intervention here.
And many other witnesses.
They also corroborate the
presence of state Asians
in inciting brutal punishment
of captured criminal suspects
in similar cases as well.
And this is just one of those quotes.
And immediately afterwards the
government they also arrested
the strike committee
members to whom Asians
had earlier provoked.
And finally the state
agents at the same time,
they photographed and
filmed these incidents
of public executions and broadcast them
as evidence of the uprising's NRP.
The state's next strategy
with dropping protesters
and strike committee members
in order to make them
vulnerable to manipulation
into publicly executing innocent people.
Not only did they drop
people, but in many cases,
they even arrested these
protestors later on
in order to cover up like
their involvement as well.
So here is a quote by a resident
in the town of Mawlamyine who recalled
how one of her acquaintances
also fell into this trap.
And last but not least state
Asians they provided guns
and homemade weapons to
neighborhood strike committees
in order to facilitate the violent attacks
and later on also arrested or
executed these people as well.
So a former student activist
here in 1988 describes
how her adopted father was framed here.
And another student union member
in the town of Yenangyaung
whose name is Maung Maung Wun,
he also met the same fate.
So at the height of the Four-eight,
the police in Yenangyaung offered to work
with the student union to take
care of the city's security.
The police chief himself also
gave Maung Maung Wun a gun
in the name of equipping the student union
to provide law and order.
And Maung Maung Wun as a
result was later accused
of stealing this gun and also
was jailed for two years.
So overall, right like I
just wanted to review here
in terms of the two different
types of strategy combinations
that the military they employed
in 1988 versus in 2007, right?
So in 2007, whereas most of
the strategies like focused
on framing protesters for
violence towards civilians
in 1988, they complimented
these types of strategies
with the incitement to work mob violence
against the innocent civilians as well.
And these states in terms of the effect
of these types of strategies
on the public perception
of the protest, these strategies
they made local residents
consider every protestors,
a potential threat, right?
Even in cases where people suspected
that the government
like had a role to play
in these types of incidents
and they suspected
the covert operation by the government,
but many of the people that I interview
they still became wary of the
agents provocateurs hiding
among protest group as you
can see in this quote here.
And moreover in 1988, right?
Like many people were also
legitimately frightened
by the killings and the
headings of civilians.
A resident of South
Oakleigh township in 1988
in this quote here shares
her traumatic memory.
And an interviewee who actually
also lives outside Yangon
in 1988, also knew about
these killings here,
the state plan TV broadcast
and therefore he himself
was also negatively affected
by this type of news as well.
So therefore, as you can see
people in general did perceive
a certain level of threats
from the protestors
and from the dissidents.
And depending on the level
of threat perception,
as well as depending on
the members of the public,
their social and gender expectations.
What I find is that
these protests observers
they either passively
avoided protest events
or withdrew their support to protestors
or actively blocked protest marches
and confronted protestors.
So first of all, regarding
the passive hostility,
so what I find is the things,
the direct confrontation
was perceived by many
people as a high risk act
where people might have
to engage in violently
with the protestors, right?
That could result in casualties.
Most peoples tend to stay away
from crowds that were elected
to harbor saboteurs, or
criminals or rioters.
And as a result in 1988, people
would rather stay at home
and guard their own
places instead of going
outside to support protests.
And similarly, since the
beginning of the 2007 events
due to fear criminals
mixing among the protesters,
many interviewees they also
stayed away from protest areas
and avoided traveling out of town
as it was considered unsafe.
Moreover, right?
So regarding active
facility, according to sorry,
before I go into that.
So according to my interviewees,
most of the bystanders
they chose not to
intervene when the military
or the police dealt with the
accused quote, unquote rioters
or criminals in 1988 or in 2007.
As people consider these
protesters as threat,
they became reluctant to support
or help during government crack downs.
And furthermore, right?
Like in the later days of
the Four-eight Uprising
due to a high level of
threat reception adult men
from various neighborhoods they
also became morally applies
to secure their own the streets
and confront protestors.
And in a matter of
days, Yangon transformed
from a friendly and peaceful community
into a hostile environment
for public demonstrations
as many of my interviewees recall here.
And these type of
neighborhoods self-organized,
vigilante teams, they
also armed themselves
and blocked protests from
passing through the areas
in order to avoid a risk
of violence directed
at their families and their neighbors
as you can see in these two quotes.
And due to these forms
of active hostility,
it has a direct effect on the
pro-democracy movement itself.
And here in this quote you can see
a former student activists
describing the difficulty
of carrying out public
protests at the time
due to the neighborhood
vigilantes like blocking
the streets.
And moreover right, another
former student activists
also commented on how the state strategies
they generated a widespread
dissension and also led
to separation between the general public
and the student protesters,
which according to him
was one of the main reasons
why the protest failed
in the end in 1988.
All right.
So in the next section, I would like to go
through the alternative
explanations for these phenomenons.
I'm sure that some of you
might also have those
questions in mind as well.
So first of all, the first
alternative explanation
is regarding the government threat,
sorry, regarding government reward, right?
So where the disruptive
and hostile civilians,
like mostly people who received
rewards from the regime.
So from many of the existing
studies as well as reports,
we know that state-hired violent
Asians have been involved
in attacking pro-democracy
activists in Myanmar, right?
So for example, a
student activist in 1988,
they are among my
interviewees also remembers
how the government appointed
administrators in his own word
who clearly were regime
supporters requested informers
to come watch and arrest
activists in his area.
And in 2007, another witness
who lived near the protest side
also recalled how the
state-hired ducks came to crush
the protesters as well.
And other studies have also
shown, right, like based
on the information and
evidence that they have gather
they have also described how in some cases
of the civilian disruption in
1988, that people were hired
and trained to attack
and kill the protesters.
So, however, since the
Burmese dictatorship,
since they limited the number
of the reward recipients
and the hired agents, even
though these people were involved
in any type of protest or
violence, they did not make up
the majority of the cases.
And indeed like most of
the civilians who disrupted
the activists or who became
hostile to where the activists,
as I find from my own interview data,
they do not receive rewards
prior to the actions.
And in fact, like most of
the urban Burmese population
at that time were burdened,
like by poor public services
and lack of social security,
which made them become dissatisfied
with the regime at the first place.
And therefore a civilian
hostility in my case studies
was mostly not motivated
by the regime's work.
And how about the
government's threats, right?
So where members of the
general public threatened
to cooperate with the
government crackdown leading
to hostility and disruption
toward the protesters.
Even though the security forces
they didn't threaten
civilians in terms of, sorry,
even though the security forces state,
they did threaten the civilians.
I find that actually this did not have
any significant effect in
terms of the civilian hostility
in the cases of 1988 and 2007 events.
So first of all, people
might have been threatened
to stay away from protest
sites or not to support
the protest but there was no
evidence that they were forced
to actively confront or to
actively block the activists.
And second, among the people
that I have interview,
if they themselves have
experienced like these types
of threats, like from the
military, from the soldiers,
from the police, telling
them, requesting them, right,
like not to go out to support
or to watch the protest event
they would detail those
kinds of experiences
very clearly, right?
But at the same time, like, as
they were talking about that,
they also express, right,
like how their own traumatic
impression of the rumors
about violence or the actual
violence that the protestors
and the dissidents had carry
out also had made them become
more reluctant as well as
feeling more threatened
and also becoming more hostile toward
these protesters as well.
So those two things,
they could also happen
at the same time and the interviewees
they were readily shared about
those types of experiences.
And secondly, like many
interviewees they also detailed
how their neighbors and
their mosque pagodas
and churches even refuse to comply
with the government's order.
And many of them also offer shelter
to the movement participants.
So therefore the government
press were mostly irrelevant
in these case studies in terms of shaping
the civilian hostility and disruption.
And what about in terms of
ethnic difference, right?
So in this case, as Burma
Buddhists were thought
to make up, I mean, they
make up the vast majority
of the population and therefore
they also were thought
to make out the vast majority
of the urban pro-democracy protestors.
So in this case where non
Burma, like more likely
to engage in disruption
and the hostilities
toward the protesters.
So based on the data
that I have collected,
there are cases where the
existing ethnic tension hindered
a non-Burma from supporting the activists.
So for instance, a Karen men
who is an ethnic minority
living in Yangon in 2007,
he shared how his current neighborhood
was not really bothered
much by the state repression
of the ethnic Burma monks and protestors.
And this is because many
ethnic minority populations
they regarded Burma people as
their oppressors for decades.
Therefore the protester's
ethnicity background
also made them appear as
a quote unquote villains
to these minority neighborhoods
and also deter the support
from these neighborhoods who
were the protesters as well.
However, like even though,
like this is one instance
that I have found like
during the interview,
but other evidence that
I have like collected
via my fieldwork have
also shown that observers
who were Burma Buddhist themselves,
they were also engaged, right?
Like in these forms of
hostility and these forms
of disruption due to
the impression like all
of the protestors as a
dangerous, a physical threat
to their neighborhood.
So, overall, right?
I also think that these
findings from my research
and they also have relevant implications
for the current case of
the post-school Myanmar
in 2021 as well.
So from most of the
existing reports and studies
that we have seen, that
(indistinct) recently,
they have also used by these
similar types of strategies,
both employing public, as
well as covert propaganda
to manipulate narratives about
protesters and frame them
as criminals in order
to turn public opinion
against the resistance and in favor
of state repression, right?
So with regard to public
propaganda to frame protestors
of conducting violence
against public interests,
for example, the military
control Myanmar TV,
they recently aired an interview
with a monk who claimed
that NLD supporters burn down
a village and also compare NLD
to the Taliban, right?
Which is essentially
associating NLD members
with criminal images that would resonate
with the majority of
Burmese Buddhist audience
many of whom might also
have discrimination
against people of Muslim heritage.
And in a similar vein in just last June,
the state media report they also accused
the national unity government
and other resistance forces
of quote, communicating with
international terrorists
and also insurgent group to grasp
the state power by force unquote.
Moreover, the military controlled
Ministry of Information,
they have also started publishing books
that accused anti-religion
movement of being
a quote unquote, a revolution
to bring back vote cheaters.
The military also disseminated newsletters
that labeled protests
as rioters as anarctic
and as sabotage activity.
So very similar types of rhetorics
that we have witnessed back
in before 2010 as well.
On top of that, regarding
with covert strategies,
the tatmadaw recently, they
have also have mastered
in their social media repertoire
and therefore they have
spread online disinformation
under the guise of ordinary
observers in order to build
an echo chamber, right effect
a echo chamber reinforcing
their official propaganda.
And numerous reports have
found that state court chose
to have engaged in
disseminating this information
about anti-government protesters
with false accusations
and manipulated images of violence.
So for example, as you can
see, in these kinds of images
on social media, the pro
military social media accounts,
they claim the security
forces did not kill protesters
but it was a third party that
was responsible referring
to other protestors and other members
of different resistance forces.
And some protestors were
even falsely accused
of killing the police or raping women.
Other pro-military accounts
have also accused anti-regime
dissidents who have turned
to violent methods of being
manipulated by foreign forces
and Islamist groups like
the ISIS and the Taliban,
and even suggest without enough evidence
that Muslims were behind the attacks.
Yeah.
So not only in the post-Myanmar in 2020,
we would also find very
similar and familiar types
of strategies in other cases,
beyond Myanmar as well.
So based on my own survey
of the existing literature
as well as existing reports
on the space oppression
of the civic space, other state leaders
have also combined like these strategies
either in terms of framing
protesters for violence
or inciting protestor
toward committing violence
toward civilian targets,
they will also combine decided strategies
in order to provoke anti
protestor's hostility, right?
So in this table, you can find
like some of those examples
where state leaders across
Asia, Europe and Africa,
and the Americas have simultaneously
spread this information
both publicly and covertly and
going one step further like
to what a number of pocketed
movements, political elites
in the US, UK and Mexico,
not only actively vilified
the protesters but also
employed Asians provocateurs
who urge funded and also armed
protesters viling sabotage
as well.
So, therefore, right, like as we can see
these very familiar
strategies being employed
in different political regime context
and also in the current
context of Myanmar,
I hope that the findings
that I have presented today,
like based on my research
on the case of Myanmar
between 1988 and 2010 could
also offer some insights
and also some relevant
perspectives to help us understand
the implications of these
strategies in the case
of the post-Myanmar and in other cases
around the world as well.
Yeah, so in conclusion, by
conducting the analysis like
on the emergence of civilian hostility
toward pro-democracy protests
in the Myanmar context,
I would say that like
my research right now
it compliments the current
literature on the 1988
and 2007 events by presenting
a more comprehensive picture
of an unimportant yet
largely neglected component
of the state suppression
strategies to what dissent.
And by illustrating these
mechanisms I also hope
to contribute to the
Burma studies literature
by refuting the claims
that the more participants
in 1988 were exceptional
or were particularly quote
unquote savage, right,
like in any sense.
They did not automatically become violent
when there were no
functioning state institutions
and as the Myanmar junta and
some scholars have claimed
on the other hand like most
people they were disgusted
and they were traumatized
by the public executions
of the criminal suspects.
And the strike committee members
moreover they were mainly
under the influence of
the state incitement
when they engage in such
types of collective assault.
And my study is also mixed
contributions here toward
the social movement and the
authoritarianism literature
as well.
So first it highlights
the authoritarian
regime's deceptive tactics
as an important part in their toolbox
to manufacture a hostile environments
for contentious actors and in
order to suppress the sense.
And this would also deepen our
understanding of mechanisms
for authoritative
survival, like, especially
during critical times of public uprisings
beyond the conventional models
of cooptation and repression.
And I propose that this
finding can serve as a unique
and valuable evidence for
advocacy against the suppression
of civic space as human rights
activists and journalists,
they might expose the covert
strategies and raise awareness
among the general public
and international community
in order to deter the state leaders
from employing these
tactics in the future.
And in another part of my
dissertation I also find
that activists might also
neutralize these face strategies
by actively debunking the
state this information
by think vigilant to the
incitement to violence
and also by coordinating
collective support,
like from the general
public to what protesters.
And the resulting support and
protection by the civilians
in contrast to hostile
disruption would increase
the activist survival and
commitment to the movement
and foster movement resilience
in the face of sacred passion as well.
However, due to the constraint
of the presentation time today.
So I think I would probably,
if you're interested
in reading more about
that part of my research
I can also share with you a
copy of my dissertation as well.
So thank you very much for listening.
- Thank you, Van. This is
really fascinating talk.
I'm going to open it up to discussion now.
I will moderate.
I have some questions of my own,
but I'll reserve them until
we get a few from people
in the audience here.
So if you can raise your
hand using the chat function,
not the chat function but
the reaction function,
then I'll see your hand go up.
But I see that we have two
questions in the chat already.
So let me ask, I'll start
with the Lisa Brooten.
If you don't mind just
asking your question,
or if you prefer me to
read it, I will read it.
And then there's another
question from Jackson Bond.
And then while we take these questions,
anyone else put your hand up
and I will find time to call on you.
- I am happy to ask directly.
Thank you for that presentation.
I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about what you see
in terms of differences
of citizen responses today
compared to today's state
violence and state misinformation
compared to what your respondents told you
about the situation in ADH in 2007.
- Yes. Thank you very much
for your question Lisa.
So I think, so just in terms of the work
that I'm currently
conducting, like regarding
the current situation.
So I have been able to conduct
any kind of systematic study,
like where I could interview
or survey people on the ground.
Most of the work that I
have been doing right now
is in terms of surveying the landscape
of social media content in
Myanmar and therefore like based
on that type of content I think
that there could also be in a way findings
that might not be comparable
to the situation before 2010, right?
So what I find in terms of
the social media content
that I have online so far
in terms of where I studied
the top most viral content on Facebook
in Myanmar during the past few months.
Most of the contents in
terms on my users in Myanmar,
they have been very supportive,
like the pro-democracy
content and at the same time
they have also been very
actively exposing incidents
of state violence online.
And at the same time
regarding others saying,
listen this information I show
some of the examples right,
in the presentation in
terms of alleging Anodea
being associated with
Taliban or ISIS or stuff.
Those types of disinformation
are their indexes
however, among the most viral contents,
they do not make it to the
top which could also indicate
that most of the on online users
and they have been somewhat
right, become more vigilant
against these types of disinformation.
And it could also indicate
that by being online,
whether it be being on social media,
these particular group of population,
they have also been more
exposed to alternative
and this course, right
from people that support
the resistance itself, right?
So which could also affect
the way that they view
the state disinformation as well.
However, I could not speak
in terms of the population
who might not be online, right?
Who might not be exposed to these types
of alternative discourses
and also these efforts
by activists to debunk
the status information
on social media.
So for people that like
have mostly consumed content
via traditional form of like
TV or radio or newspaper
I thought that that is a part that I think
could have very different
types of the findings.
Yeah, but I've yet been
able to look into that.
Yeah. Yeah.
- Thank you very much.
Nhu do you wanna ask your question now?
- Yeah. Thank you, Erik.
And thank you Van for
a great presentation.
I really enjoyed it and as you ran off
on your research super
interesting and relevant.
So my question has to do
with trying to understand
the logic of suppression
on a logic of governance
of the state in relation
to societal opposition.
And what I'm not clear
about is when and why
will a state use this strategy?
In other words, while we
know that, and we can see,
as you show your last line the combination
of this sort of framing,
trying to delegitimize
the opposition versus a
combination of also strive
to incite violence also
to delegitimize opposition
and participants.
These elements can be found
in many other cases, right?
In many incidents, both within
Myanmar and outside Myanmar.
So the question is when would
even the Myanmar government,
when does the Myanmar
government decide to apply
the strategy and when it does not,
and then why do some states
do and why some states do not?
And that's something
that I would love to hear
your thoughts on that.
Thanks so much.
- Yeah. Thank you for
the great question Nhu.
So, first of all,
regarding like the question
of the decision by a state when not to use
a certain type of strategy,
I don't have much confidence
there to be honest.
I will say that I know when they do apply
these types of strategies,
but in terms of why they decided to do so
I can only have guesses.
I think that particularly
like in the case of Myanmar
before 2010, right?
We could also find that there
could be different reasons.
So, first of all during 1988,
like we have a different general
at the top of the government
versus in 2010, right.
So they could have different
types of strategies
to suppress dissent.
And furthermore it could also be the case
that as many people
would also know the scale
of the protests in 1988 was much wider
and much more encompassing
of the different groups
of the population.
So the traditional, or more conventional,
more conservative tablet strategies like
to repress, or to suppress
dissent that they have try,
might have not worked as
much as they had hoped.
And so therefore they added
this additional step, right.
But at the same time, I think we also find
that these exact strategies probably not,
but very similar strategies,
they have also been employed recently like
by the Myanmar military, after
the coup in February as well
due to the fact that a lot of the people
that are on the advisory council
to the military right now,
they were also related
to the Ne Win family
or like to the previous
leaders of the previous regime.
So, I think that there
could be different types
of factors, right regarding,
I would say like the style
of suppression of each of the leaders,
and at the same time it could
also be the situation, right.
That they find themselves under as well.
And in, regarding like thinking broader,
more and more broadly in
terms of beyond Myanmar
and in other states.
And so, first of all
what I would like to say
is that the data that I have right now
it might also be incomplete, right.
Especially regarding
the covert strategies,
we only know them when we have like
these types of information being released
to the public, right.
So we only, for example, in the case
of the US COINTELPRO operation
that those are only know,
like after we already
have like a public
investigation into these cases.
So it could also be that the application
of these types of covert strategies
are much more widespread and the parent
could also look different
from what we know now.
However, one thing that I
think that could also offer
maybe one possible
explanation for the valuation
in terms of which states
do or do not employ
these types of strategies
to provoke public hostility.
I would say that for certain states
and in certain regimes
that are more willing
to directly crackdown to
directly repress protests
without fear of getting backlash
from the public population,
from the members of the public,
they would find less meat
to employ these things
more covert strategies.
Yeah, and so that's just
one possible explanation,
but love to discuss more
if you have other ideas.
- Thanks. I'm gonna to
ask my question now.
There's a little mystery that
I'm working with in my head,
as I'm listening to this talk.
It's not your research
it's just like the question
that I can't stop having.
And it's about the methodology
a little bit where you can
conduct interviews with people
and the people will say,
"Look, I know that the state
was sending a provocateur,
or I know the state
was inciting violence."
I know X what's happening, right.
Like they are able in
recounting and telling the story
to distinguish the state's
kind of provocations,
all the elements that you've
described, all the strategies
and styles that you've described, right.
Like people can figure it out, right.
They're not fooled by it, right?
At the same time, it seems to work
in a weird way too, right?
Like there's moments like
in the heat of the moment,
it seems almost that people, yeah,
they do get kind of worried
about those protestors.
And said maybe there's a
seed of doubt or concern
that they don't know who's violent or not,
or something like that, right?
And so I guess my question
is, how do we develop
a kind of theory about the
way in which people both know
that the state is, or the
junta is doing this machination
and trickery and deception, right?
But at the same time, they
then feel themselves compelled
almost be a little bit worried
about those protestors,
even though they know
the protestors actually
they may politically be on the same side
as them actually, right.
In some sense, right.
Have you thought a little
bit about how to reconcile
that kind of conundrum a little bit
and how is it that people
when they recount the story
can actually say," Oh yeah,
it was the state provocateur."
But then when you look at your
data, there's lots of people
who don't realize that it seems, right?
- Yeah, so I think to
answer that question,
first of all, I think that
there are two parts here,
like in terms of what
the state provocateur
is what they did, right?
And also, secondly, in terms
of these types of actions
what kind of effect they
have like on the protesters
and on the kind of protest observers.
I would say that in
terms of like recounting
these types of experiences, like people
could have pinpointed, right.
In terms of like these are
instances where I find it
so strange that you would
have like these people
who would come and provoke violence
but at the same time
later on you find them
being ready with a camera
and then they're also the one
who would report to the states to arrest
these types of people.
So that's something that
people can piece together.
I do not think that is very much
in terms of being a cognitive dissonance,
as you know people also find
that they themselves are
worried that I'm sure, right.
So we might believe the protesters
however, how many people out
there are real protesters
and how many people are out there,
they are the state Asians.
And that is something that
they do not know and exactly
I think that this is a type
of strategy that I also find
in a way has been accountable, right.
Like for in accountable
for creating or increasing
a distrust amongst society.
And overall this level of distress, right?
Like when it increases
then people would also find
themselves to be less willing
to have like strangers
interacting with them
or to supporting these
people that they don't know
where they come from, what they have done
or what they might do to
their neighborhoods as well.
So this is something that,
where even when people are aware
of the state strategies doesn't mean
that the strategies won't have effect.
And this also be something
that the regime themselves,
they might have counted on as well.
Yeah.
- In some sense, the strategy
plants so much uncertainty
that it creates it just
makes it impossible
to ever feel secure in who
you know and who is who
and what's going on, right?
I mean, in some sense, kind of similar
to this fake news phenomenon
like once you plant the idea
that there may be fake news,
you can't undo that uncertainty
or anything like that, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that's exactly the case there.
Yeah, and then like people
at least in terms of people
that I have interview they also will find
that even if the protesters themselves
they did not originally
plan to conduct violence
against innocent civilians,
but they are susceptible
to work publication to
these types of violence.
So this is something that also made it,
I would say make the civilian observer
is that they have a very high level
of track perception
regarding how they think
about these protesters.
Yeah.
- Thanks for that.
Thuy, do you wanna ask your question now?
- Thank you.
First, I was impressed when I got the news
about the presenter Van
Tran, NSE, Vietnamese,
and she doing research in Burma.
And that was really impressive.
So, and thank you for
an interesting topic.
I am not doing English, I'm
like political science in Burma
but I'm interested in the
demographics that you show.
I see that there were more men than women.
(indistinct)
The rest is like in 2007 is the more men
than women compared to 88.
And I'm not in the protest,
unless I'm sometimes
some one or two years,
last year sometime I heard
from the new, I'm not
sure is that the fake news
about the protest that the(indistinct)
because of the years later
that the men don't roast
the under of the women.
So that to me that's less
smart and that for me is smart.
It also remind me about
Vietnamese Women Movement
during the war.
You may know about the famous saying,
(speaking foreign language)
during the American war in Vietnam.
So yeah, Vietnamese in Burma.
So how you see the
Burma women now compared
to the Burmese women in the next.
To me I see because I'm
doing research related
to trivia women history.
So I see women like Vietnamese women.
(indistinct) but now we
lose that motivation.
We lose that effort.
Now we more like accept what
we have compared to before.
So in both my answer, I we see now,
like more male than female professor,
like later injuries that can
you have more demographics,
but I didn't see you.
Thank you.
- Sure, sure. Yeah, Yeah.
I'll say thank you so
much for your questions.
So I think that it's also like
a really great question too,
because I think that you had probably like
a really sharp observation
there because also according
to my own observation, right.
And also based on studying
the existing reports
and documentations of the
protest events like before 2010,
most of them, despite the
fact that we have the leader
of the main opposition party being women,
but most of the protest
events at that time
they were participated by men
and they were also led by men as well.
So during my field work, I
also had to intentionally,
I asked my interlocutors to help me
to recruit female interviewees,
people who themselves
were also experienced and either observed
or directly participate in
these types of protests.
And at the same time, what we find
is that types of like
rhetoric like these feminists.
Rhetorics and these feminist
demands that we see in 2020,
these are the things
that I did not find all
in terms of the most popular demands
or rhetorics like before 2010.
So in a way to me it was
a very encouraging sign
and I really hope to see
more of that type of development as well.
Yeah, Yeah, I hope that
answered your question somewhat.
Yeah.
- Thank you Van and thank
you Thuy and everyone else
for these great questions.
We're at the end of the
formal time for our Q and A,
what I will do at this
moment is stop the recording
and then I'll leave the Zoom open
for informal chit chat after this point.
But please join me everyone for a moment
to thank Dr. Van Tran
for this fantastic talk.
So thank you very much.
- Thank you everybody
for attending for yeah,
very interesting questions too.